when netflix started cutting its marvel
shows loose in 2018
viewers everywhere made sure to voice
their displeasure with their decision
the premature loss of programs like
daredevil luke cage and jessica jones
led to serious social media outcry
including the desire for the actors to
make the leap to the big screen
to many these versions of the marvel
comics characters are their defining
live-action portrayals
and are more than worthy of joining the
marvel cinematic universe
however losing their shows and their
canon status means there's potential for
widespread recasting
down the line many fans were opposed to
this idea and remained especially vocal
in their desire to see john bernthal
retain his job as franco castle better
known as the punisher
first introduced as a supporting
character and daredevil's second
season bernthal's take on frank castle
immediately won fan support
his ability to sell the punisher's cold
outlook on life
while still maintaining his
vulnerability as a mentally damaged war
veteran
earned him a devoted fanbase even after
his solo show's cancellation
punisher fans remain hopeful that if
castle ever does make the jump to
feature films
he'll once again be left in the capable
hands of bernthal however the walking
dead alum has gone on the record saying
that those in charge will have to meet
one requirement if he's to even consider
bringing frank castle to life again the
geek house show youtube channel got the
chance to sit down with john bernthal
and discussed his time as frank castle a
bit diving into his preparation to
become the morally questionable punisher
after making it clear that he believes
that frank castle belongs first and
foremost to the fans of the comic books
bernthal said i have to um go as deep
into it and dig into the wound of it as
as
as deeply as i as i can't
went on to explain that while he doesn't
consider himself a method actor
he does put a lot of dedication into his
roles to create the best product
possible
bernthal also sheds some light on the
key factor of castle's backstory
that made his version of the character
so harrowing he admitted that he could
never have played the role if he wasn't
a father and husband in real life
saying that it was crucial to understand
what it felt like to love someone more
than himself
according to bernthal only after he knew
how it felt to
be willing to give your life for them um
can you begin to sort of imagine what it
would be like if they were taken from
you
the loss of his wife and daughter is
what pushes the punisher over the edge
in a way frank castle's canonical origin
story is a bit like a classic
greek tragedy that bleeds into an
extended revenge story
so there's certainly plenty of emotion
for an actor to mine
when asked if there was any news he
could give on a potential comeback as a
gun-toting vigilante in the future
burn thoughts he's that there's uh
there's always hope
while he made sure to communicate how
humbled he was by the tremendous fan
support
for his performance as frank castle
bernthal stressed that returning to the
role for him depends on more than just
the opportunity presenting itself
it's not about whether we do it it's
about getting it right and and doing
the version that that the fans really uh
deserve
while the punisher's mcu introduction
still feels far off
it's not out of the realm of possibility
that john bernthal could someday don the
iconic black skull shirt
once more if and when that happens fans
of bernthal's personal assurance that
he'll do his best to do frank castle
justice
when when we get the call to go
i'll be ready and i'll make sure that um
i do everything i can to make sure that
we do it right or we we won't do it at
all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one